why why this show on top of being an
actor a producer director philosopher as
well yeah but this is a teaching this is
a teaching opportunity and I'm all for
that I think that education is one of
our major shortcomings today we must be
less inspired and we must teach them and
the younger we can start the better the
box office success when the Shawshank
Redemption came out with Dumb and Dumber
that's you know just the juxtaposition
of box office shelf and got really good
reviews but because nobody could say
Shawshank Redemption
it didn't get word-of-mouth and I don't
care how much you promote a film if you
don't have word-of-mouth emai promoting
it people have to be able now in to go
and say listen I saw this really
terrific film it was called shank Sam
Jim chunk got on the elevator in LA one
day and the lady said oh I just saw you
in the hudsucker production
so that was the reason it was not a
box-office success
no word-of-mouth at all you just watched
two amazing clips of Morgan Freeman take
the next three minutes to sit quietly
and think about how you can apply them
to your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]